get excited for the video time to look
at reddit today we're looking at ask
ready such great free content another
day another free content I like how the
top one here says how do you feel about
the recent YouTube videos profiting off
people's ass dreaded threads that's not
what's happening and we got to start
giving credit to all these individuals
that are stealing other people's memes
no dr. Phylis is one of these guys
actually asked my permission to read my
story on this show so I hope most of
these youtubers dr. Billy is that all I
had to do to not get a copy just ask
come on Sony come on when you realize
this will also be on YouTube inside
surprise no matter Oh what is happening
which celebrity is not as nice as they
seemed you know I'm super nice
you are I'm which I'm what I'm what at
least I'm honest in my videos about how
I am but I don't I don't put on oh
you're so nice you're so nice you aren't
you're the nicest yeah all right let's
see what celebrities are not nice Luke
Bryan he's a POS they said where the
Frick is Luke Bryan but if the guy from
like I have no idea this is all you can
tell just by looking at it I don't mean
yeah I don't need someone I'm ready
anyone that dressing looks like this
sorry Luke we don't know anything about
you and this could be completely
defamatory but you're a douchebag we get
to see our TV back there for what are
you there for me it looks like a
freaking fire hazard
load and kill everybody with wires
coming from it that's what I'm hoping
for why I am sitting here making another
happy wheels hoping that's a TV will one
day just sorry this meme is taking way
longer than I expected
thank you can you put it Frank Sinatra
once called my grandfather and blackjack
table at a blackjack table just for
sitting there well it sounds like your
granddad isn't so yeah exposed your
granddad and not Frank Sinatra jeez I
mean you read a blackjack table you got
the good card someone sits down and
messes up the cards you getting there
next up was a waitress at a restaurant
that had celebrity client Larry David
super nice yes good job Larry now like a
bald man he's sweaty he's sweaty Oh
sweat Alec Baldwin there's just
everything I can't watch Alicia Keys I
weren't security at a local concert
venue for ten years and she was
absolutely the meanest artist that I
ever rubbed elbows with oh they'll be
rubbing her elbows there this weird
person being so close I was able to hear
every word she said to her assistant and
he wasn't pretty
she basically badmouth the entire group
she had something negative to say about
almost everyone's outfit in appearance
considering how long it was I hope she
has grown up
remember how we do the meet and greets I
remember you and I illicit next to each
other and we had this what's it called
like the hand sanitizer
yeah it just feels so mean to like you
made all this family
though you think you get sick all the
germs and stuff however that to ever sit
massage you and people are like you know
get your autograph
and then they'd like get the pity
autograph from me and like thanks say
hey man who you are but hey Silas I'm
like you I'd have to say that someone I
know man Adam Levine backstage it was
mad because he told Adam you guys are
good and Adam said I know you walked oh
I thought it was funny because the guy
took it so personal I mean come on
they know right they know everybody
loves them it's fine Adam Levine and see
the guy in maroon 5 I think so
all I can say is I met Mark Hamill at a
deli and he was so damn cool kind and
generous I asked for a picture and he
happily obliged I'm on the tall side
six-five fished I didn't even tall when
I went to lean down to get the photo he
said no leaning down and instead I
instead cut on his tippy toes true Jedi
Mind stick man this make me feel back
it's like more and more now when I get
recognized I'd say no if the situation
is really bad my game I mean my said
drove back home it was really late and
we were super hungry we drove to this
back Thomas drive-thru and we're like we
just don't we just want to eat we don't
want to be recognized and all these kids
come up to us and one of them moms Coco
was like sorry I'm just trying to have
dinner and I just feel I feel like the
worst you're gonna be in here somewhere
you guys aware obviously like I feel
like the worst person ever I just wish
like they understand yeah just eating or
doing something I don't want to exit my
car to take a photo
yeah well it's like a lot of these a lot
of these situations like the ones that
has read it I say if you go out you have
like a day you're walking in like for
eight hours like 7 to 8 hours you're
getting asked to take pictures and stuff
and that one person that catches you
when you're like right it's going on
here making a post about it cuz it's
like they're their one-on-one experience
even though they're like the 800 person
you've seen that day I'm at beauty Pat
one time it was a 3 a.m.
was asleep and I was in his room and he
was renting called the police on me I
used to know someone who produced a
Tobey Maguire movie and claimed that
he's not a very nice person at all no no
no he was better man
Tiger Woods is a goddamn dick who
thought who would have thought it
I made a shirt at a party once one of
the rudest most deeply light people come
on we just got you're at the same party
don't we didn't come and be cool with us
you're all right you know another dude
has to take a picture with me it's like
how about you go get another drink
instead walked off goddang yeah but
jerks bother and poor uh sure
he's just tried there to support his
friend and everyone's like making it
about uh sure like he's just you know
the man right yeah yeah I'm sure uh sure
you should be thankful for him being
that's right because he gave you this
story that you can share and read it
that gave you a lot of points yeah
you only thought about that your brother
my friend met Patrick Stewart in a pub
during his stag do since it was a stag
they figured they would make it
memorable say it's friend approached his
search division says I'm sorry to ask
you this but Stewart interrupts and says
then maybe you can set yourself up for
that one
I'm sorry to add this that's this well
then don't ask me if you're sorry just
don't do it you won't be sorry about it
all right got him
Oh God what's a stag do isn't it when
someone's getting married stag party
I don't know stag party yeah yeah I
guess so what what's the do though you
dude the stag party it was like a
mountain do you do mountains dudes at
this stag party yes
Wow Robin Williams oh I see something oh
no don't don't even he's live in my
neighborhood and I'd sometimes see him
in a favorite restaurant he'd be tucking
his face out of you so it's clear he
didn't want to be disturbed
so nobody did once it's all gone walk up
to him and say something I couldn't hear
and Roberts a dude do you mind I'm just
trying to have dinner with my family
yeah can't blame them in the least yeah
but that's the thing honestly I hope
you're saying understand that when
you're just gonna do something with my
dad once met Adam Sandler at a bar in
the Bahamas he was super down-to-earth
an awesome guy well I've been to like
conventions and stuff with like other
guy like anime like video game
conventions with like other people in
the business you know let's hear it it's
always like - it's always like the most
insignificant people that are like the
worst
do you know who I am no actually care
i've voice-acted one character in a
popular video game that's all they were
done I'm a diva now I was like I think
mission completed here today we're
biggest tangent of all time basically
thank us credit for letting us steal
your content we're not worthy
we of course asked everyone for their
permission yeah obviously hmm and what's
the weight lie about is it okay thanks
Ken for joining really hey thanks for
having me
let's make em not irrelevant anymore
check out Ken's channel he just videos
guys let's give him a penny stuff at
least this just just throw it out there
man you know let me feel like I'm part
of something where the hell is my pity
son okay what is something I couldn't
talk about room it but we did last time
the most dangerous game are you still
sick right yeah of course
I turned my notification off there all
right guys see you later bye tuber
simulator it's now so relevant that it's
got a brand new minigame crania drop the
crane and get fresh items only available
in the washing machine like game and you
say there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and legs guys leg
[Music]